this video is sponsored by expressvpn
[Music]
let me show you something from a behind
the scenes clip from terence malik's
film knight of cubs
a road scholar and academic philosopher
turned filmmaker malik made
two critically acclaimed films in the
1970s before he disappeared unannounced
from hollywood
for 20 years okay what you're seeing
here
is very rare here we see terrence malik
working on set since he's returned from
his absence he's forbidden his face from
being used in any publicity for his
films
and he's never spoken publicly unless he
isn't being recorded you can tell the
person filming the behind the scenes
knows they've made a mistake because as
soon as malik comes into the frame they
quickly
pan over to hide him again this means we
don't have malik himself
as a direct source for why his style
developed in a certain way and looks the
way it does
but we can still learn a lot by
examining what
those who have worked with him have said
and by drawing conclusions from the
relationship we see
between his style and the thematic
content of his work
the tree of life malek's most renowned
film juxtaposes an intimate story of
family life in the 1950s
against a sequence that showcases the
creation
of the universe on a cosmic scale
what malek seems interested in is not
just
telling the story of individual
characters but
situating these characters within a much
broader context perhaps it is the same
desire to situate characters within a
broader context
that led malik to use wider lenses with
deeper focus later in his career a
development that played a big role in
shaping his specific look with these
wide lenses
even when the camera approaches a
character for a close-up
they are always part of their
environment
almost inseparable from the natural
world
that surrounds them
there's a certain kind of shot that is
iconically terence malik
it's probably one of these kinds of
shots that springs to mind when i
mention his name
these shots like the films they are
inside of
tend to provoke strong reactions for
some people
they're a suggestion towards something
profound
the inclusion of something grander a
kind of visual poetry symbolizing things
that
lay beyond the frame for others they're
a baffling distraction
an irrelevant frustrating diversion from
what the films are supposed to be doing
telling a story this polarization
between the people for whom this kind of
thing resonates and the people who find
it aggravating exists
all around terence malik not just in
response to his finished films but
among those who have worked with him in
response to how
he works some like long time
collaborator and cinematographer
emanuel lebeske find the way malik works
profound
he said working with terry has changed
my life i'm a different parent
i'm a different husband and i'm a
different friend i see
nature in a different way since i
started working with terry
others like james horner the composer
for the new world
or adrian brody who was initially cast
as the lead for the thin red line and
then cut
out of the film expressed frustration
and exasperation
at his methods but whether you love it
or hate it
malek's style is undeniably unique
this unique style is something that
malek's critics tend to disregard as
extraneous and arbitrary made up of
choices that
prioritize the pursuit of visual beauty
at the expense of character
and story but far from being arbitrary i
think it's a unique style that developed
organically alongside a unique approach
not just a filmmaking but what a film
can be
even if you're not a fan of malik's work
he's a filmmaker who's been
incredibly influential as i talked about
in a recent video he's been a major
influence on best director oscar winner
chloe zhao
for her work on nomad land and many
other directors have been
influenced significantly by his work i
think it's an interesting exercise to
try to understand not just
what this style is that's been so
influential but why
it was developed in the way that it was
his films are all
very very connected with each other and
they're very recognizably his work
but it's very tough to put your finger
on why that is or what you're seeing in
that
the technique is not immediately obvious
to try to break down the technical
elements that make up the style
let's start with these iconic mallet
shots while malik's whole style isn't
defined by these shots
breaking down these moments that feel
stereotypically malik
is a good place to start there are
several easily identifiable
elements we can find here we see the use
of natural light
the use of wide-angle lenses and the
deep focus that i mentioned at the
beginning
but there's also a fairly unusual
positioning of the camera or movement of
the camera
it's generally lower to the ground than
we expect to find in a film
and is often closer to the subject than
we expect for this kind of wide-angle
lens
the camera often looks upward in a way
that's not
often encountered in narrative film and
the way the camera moves is also
significant to the construction of these
shots
the camera movement is often very
unmotivated and
subjective the movement isn't clearly
motivated by the movement of objects in
the frame but the movement doesn't seem
to be marking
a specific emotional beat for the
characters
in the way a crash zoom often would
instead the camera
seems to have a life of its own and
interests of its own
natalie portman talking about her work
on knight of cups
described lubesky and his steadicam
operator york whitmer who would go on to
be malik's cinematographer for a hidden
life
as actors in the film they are a part of
the scene with you
you're dancing with them constantly and
you're acting with them personally
we can even see in the behind the scenes
footage from song to song that at one
point they just
hand the camera over to ryan gosling and
let him do some shooting
but it's not just the visual elements of
a shot like this that make it stand out
it's how these shots are positioned and
used inside the films
that makes them unique if used within a
larger scene they often
push the scene away from linear
continuity breaking from
the narrative of what's happening
immediately around the characters
that these shots break away from the
story being told
isn't just something that appears in the
final film
it's a reality of the way they're shot
jack fisk the production designer for
many of malik's films
says sometimes we'll be shooting
something in a film and an interesting
bird will fly by and he'll start
crawling on a tree and directing the
cameras toward that bird
one of the best sources we have for
understanding how this style developed
technically
is emmanuel lebeske or chivo someone
who's arguably been
responsible for a significant portion of
the
look we now think of as terrance malik
malek's style was evolving during his
first three films and we can see
many elements of his contemporary style
in these early films as i mentioned in
my
video essay about badlands but the first
time we see what feels like his
contemporary style fully formed
is in the new world which is where malik
and chivo's collaboration began
in the lead-up to working on the new
world chivo and malik established a
dogma
for shooting a technical set of rules
that guided how they would film
things these guidelines centered around
the use of natural light
having as clear and high resolution and
image as possible
and using fluid handheld or steadicam
movement most
of the time in a way these elements are
as much about what the image
isn't as what it is malek's contemporary
work is as much defined by the kinds of
shots
you will never see in them as it is by
the ones you do
why these rules though why this dogma
is this just what chivo and malik
thought would make the prettiest images
i don't think so here's chivo
illustrating the motivation behind the
choice to use backlight
we chose backlight not because it is
pretty but because it helps with the
evenness of the light
terry shoots out of sequence a close-up
in october might be used on a scene
later in december or somewhere else
by shooting backlight keeping softer
light on the face of the actors and
keeping the sky
white we were able to serve the story
and keep
the continuity basically chivo is
recognizing that
malik is assembling scenes from moments
captured
days or even months apart and
backlighting the characters looks good
but it also allows for a greater sense
of continuity between these shots
i think many of the choices of technique
are like this for example the choice of
steadicam
or handheld cinematography this
certainly produces
a specific aesthetic but it also enables
malik
and his actors to film in a unique way
developing this approach involved an
increasing focus on
improvisation with the use of natural
light and the freedom of the camera
the actors were given freedom to walk
and move
wherever they liked what started out as
throwing out the script to use
occasional improvisation
on thin red line in the new world
eventually led to improvising
entire films like the knight of cups i
would posit that
this visual style developed mostly in an
attempt to
allow an increasing amount of freedom
something i point to in my essay about
nomad land and its style
this freedom would allow the filming to
adapt to the way malik
wanted to work instead of having to halt
everything
to film a bird flying overhead which
would then need to be inserted into the
scene later in editing
the camera could now easily shift its
attention on the fly to incorporate the
bird into the shot itself
as his films progressed malik became
less and less interested
in constructing and imposing narratives
often working with the technique called
torpedoing where he'd have
several characters improvise a scene and
on some takes would send in
another character unannounced to disrupt
the scene
and force new kinds of improvisation
christian bale talks about
falling asleep on the set of the new
world and being awoken on camera and
told to walk into the next room and
start talking to somebody
instead of writing scripts and then
shooting them malik is using techniques
like this to collect a large number of
moments
that he and his team of editors then use
to shape into a finished film
this video focuses on why terence
malek's films
look a certain way but i must mention
editing
in the development of this look the
increasing level of freedom used in
shooting these films was matched by an
increasing level of freedom of
association
in the edit there would be no point in
capturing these drifting
fleeting improvisational moments if you
weren't also developing a style of
editing that allowed them to be used in
the film
and this is what malek did at first
incorporating improvisational moments
and nature into the narrative as
transitional pieces or parts of montages
but then shifting to making these
moments the primary building blocks
of his films with the new world where we
see the first
fully fledged example of his
cinematography
we also see the adoption of a more
impressionistic
and non-continuity style of editing
while editing isn't an element of
cinematography it definitely affects
how we feel a film looks to some degree
and i think the editing plays as much a
role in malik's
distinct style as the cinematography
does
it seemed no trouble could reach our
valley
we lift above the clouds
[Music]
but to say that malik's style arose out
of an increasing search for freedom and
fluidity and production
leaves another question unanswered
why is this freedom important to malik's
filmmaking
and what is this freedom in service of
malik in his films seems interested not
just
in putting on screen something that
exists already in his imagination
but in starting with questions and
setting out
in search of an answer through the
production of these films
[Music]
frequently in interviews with those who
have worked with him people mention
searching for moments of truth john c
reilly who appears in thin red line
called malik
not a filmmaker but a truth seeker
[Music]
we have food
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for most of these later projects malik
and his crew would shoot an immense
amount of footage crew members would
often remark that they had enough
material from one film to create several
different
films through these images and moments
combined together with non-continuity
editing
i think malik's attempting to put on
screen
emotions feelings and ideas that are
difficult to convey
through traditional narrative structure
and dialogue
malik's more recent films largely employ
non-continuity editing while continuity
editing the style of editing that
dominates most of the films and tv you
watch
has a long history non-continuity
editing
has a lesser known but still extensive
past early soviet directors like sergei
eisenstein who was working in the 1920s
were big proponents of non-continuity
editing
eisenstein believed that by removing the
obvious
spatial and temporal connection between
one shot
and the next the filmmaker could force
the audience to try to understand the
connection themselves
it's these connections and associations
between two
seemingly unrelated images that create
the potential to communicate
deeper symbolic philosophical or
emotional meanings
through cinema that's why cinema like
malik's is often described as poetic
rather than using a conventional
narrative focusing on plot characters
exposition and dialogue like a novel
would malik's films use
imagery a kind of visual and thematic
rhyming
to evoke some essence or feeling
like a poem would there's a lot of
people
who don't like malik's work i think one
reason why
is because watching this kind of movie
like reading a poem
forces you to participate imaginatively
in a way that some people find it hard
to do or don't want to do
but another reason is that i think often
things that are more
poetic like songs can be more personal
in terms of who they connect with
appreciation of
all art is subjective but to enjoy
malek's work you have to be interested
in the sort of abstract emotional ideas
he's presenting
and the unusual approach he's taking to
presenting them
but for those who do connect to his work
when they do it seems to have profound
impact i for one think malik's most
interesting and engaging work
comes from when he applies his searching
improvisational approach to the
boundaries afforded by
an existing story a hidden life which
tells the true story of franz
jaegerstadter an austrian farmer
who fought a quiet and personal battle
against nazi germany
not only assembles an authentic
representation of the world he lived in
it
but gives us a glimpse into the interior
struggle
he and his community must have gone
through
his search for answers in the story and
malik's
search for answers align the result is
one of the most
profound and engaging films i've ever
seen and a personal favorite of mine
i think malik's untraditional style is
largely born out of his
untraditional approach to film in
general
he was willing to walk away from a
successful career and film for
20 years after a growing frustration
with hollywood
and when he came back to filmmaking he
did it on his terms
he was willing to not play by the rules
because he was willing to not play at
all
and he refuses to speak for his work or
offer
explanations because both his approach
and his work aren't ultimately about
offering answers but about the process
of questioning so why do terence malek's
films
look like that this video
isn't a concrete answer it's a document
of
my search for the answer to that
question
and thank you for joining me in that
search
my sponsor for this episode is
expressvpn thank you to them for making
this video possible
there's a movie i really wanted to see
that's not out yet in the us
johann johansson's last and first men
it's only available
in singapore and a few other countries
currently and i was able to use
expressvpn to route my traffic through
singapore
and be able to legally rent the movie in
that country where it's available
when you use the internet you're always
on some kind of network which is the
internet service provider or your cell
phone carrier which means
your browsing history is exposed to your
isp
who technically can give that data over
to the government or
sell it to other companies a vpn
protects your traffic
inside a virtual private network so that
your internet service providers
can't have access to your data using a
vpn can increase your privacy
on the internet but it can also be just
really useful and helpful in some
situations have you ever encountered
a youtube video that is blocked in your
country well if you use
expressvpn you can route your traffic
through a server in another country
and get access to those videos sometimes
expressvpn is super simple to use both
on your computer and your phone
find out how you can get three months
for free by clicking the link in the
description
that's expressvpn.com
thomasflight go to expressvpn.com
thomasflight find out how you can get
three months for free when you sign up
for
[Music]
expressvpn
you